maybe it's just time i put my big girl
panties on
and talk with gino because that's
something that i'm just gonna eventually
have to get over because i want the
relationship with my mama so
i just need to buckle up and give
somebody a second chance i'm ready to
hear what you got to say
makes me unhappy and it's just part of
it
i just need you all to know there was a
lot of hurt over the past year
i had to take care of alana when i
really wasn't prepared to do that
like i was just becoming a mom myself
trying to like figure it all out on my
own
mama wasn't there you weren't around
[Music]
really a whole ole mess
please don't take this like i'm making
excuses uh because i'm not you know
there is no excuse it shouldn't have
happened period
we began using drugs as kind of
recreational
then next thing we knew we were you know
full-fledged addicted
i can look back and see some of the
things that that we were doing you know
spending all of our money pawning things
not talking to you guys
now looking back on that is like what
the hell how could we have done that you
know why did we do that
so i can see that now being clear-headed
but at the time
the drugs clouded our brains so much
that
you see what we did you know imagine
standing at the counter
of a hotel bathroom for three or four
days
literally i mean my legs would be
killing me my back would be killing me
and we still stood there and did cocaine
for days upon days
we would say hey man this is screwed up
why are we doing this you know we've
blew through another fifty thousand
dollars what the hell
you know we need to stop it's like what
the hell were we thinking
how could we have done that you know why
did we do that you know
addiction's horrible man